jeff we found this quote from you i
think you said i wanted to create
something that people will walk away
from thinking
i've never seen anything like that
before a small indie like this
can't compete with hollywood for
spectacle and star power
but we can try to make much more
interesting films at least can you
expand on that
yeah um yeah i definitely wanted to
wanted to make something that yeah that
when people walked away from
they didn't just forget about it
and you know i i forget i should
remember
i want to see it was crew brick but they
some director i remember reading
years ago said um i don't care if they
love it or hate it i want them to
remember it
and that to me that's i have more
respect and i enjoy watching films i go
for the gusto
and fail over those that just try to
appeal
to the most common denominator that's
why
not a big fan of superhero movies but i
appreciate the dc ones a hundred times
over the marvel ones
because dc made some steamers
but they're always like they always try
to do something
that's really over the top and
interesting or whatever
and whereas marvel like they all kind of
bleed together it's
and there's no consequences and you get
into that but even just in the indie
film world
how do you compete with those movies i
mean they've got
they spend more on uh you know i'm sure
their xerox budget than i had for this
whole film
um just to and so you know i'm not going
to
do them in action or spectacle
and uh star power but i can at least
try and um i can at least try and give
the audience something
that they're gonna walk away feeling
like i got a unique experience from this
and so
with that like the intent was not
necessarily to make something
that's the hard part about doing that is
you don't want to make something that's
uh too um can't think of the word right
now you don't want to make it where
it's too abstract or like audiences
aren't going to feel like
like it's worth committing to it still
make it entertaining still make it fun
you know it's uh i try to keep it fast
paced a little bit of a slow burn like
it has a slow build but once it kicks in
it's i could try to give it a good pace
there's a lot of just there is some
spectacle in it at least for a small
indie
uh but then thematically
um i don't like i don't like things that
fit into a neat little box
so uh musicians i like often
do a lot of fusion type of stuff they
mix different genres
um and same with filmmakers uh
you know some of the films that inspired
me when i was first kind of getting my
start in the night you know as a
teenager in the 90s you know watching
tarantino stuff which is often
unclassifiable for a genre
watching you know uh movies like
california like
i guess it's a thriller but it's also
it's funny i mean i still quote that
movie
brad pitt's my arguably my favorite role
next to his
his role in true romance um which is
another one
natural-born killers uh some of these
films that
go dark and they're like they kind of
challenge your own morality as an
audience but at the same time they're
funny they have characters that you fall
in love with
uh even though they're horrible and uh
um
and just you know deal with deeper human
themes and social and political themes
so i kind of fell in love with movies
like that and i feel like
we have an industry that needs to sell
things and so they need to know how to
sell it so it needs to be a certain
product
and that in a way has really
homogenized so much of storytelling
and my own little way i wanted to try
and like break out of that and not
not think about oh well this is a horror
movie so i can't do this or
if i do this um you know fans of the
vampire genre are gonna be like well
this isn't a real vampire movie
um and more just let the let the story
go where it needs to go to be the story
it needs to be
uh without worrying about making it
marketable um now unfortunately for my
distributors
makes their job a lot harder it's funny
you mentioned the movie california from
was that 1993
yeah that's it okay because the
bartender in your film the opening
scenes
reminded me of juliet lewis she had a
very similar sort of
not just look but the sort of the
character type as well
yeah you know what and uh
we that julia lewis character and julia
lewis in any movie is one of my
favorites
uh she's just phenomenal but in that one
she is
she's just i mean phenomenal so
both adorable and trashy
and um and
i just i absolutely love her in that
movie as well and so
i'm sure on some level like
just stylistically those movies
definitely impacted
uh you know on blood from stone i was
the uh this wardrobe
and stylist person as well so um
you know basically every article in
clothing you see in that i
not only found it purchased or at the
very least uh agreed to
but um yeah so i'm sure my own styling
of the movie was probably heavily
inspired by
by that film and that goes back to what
you said too about not everybody wants
these like
films that are in a neat little box
these popcorn movies some people
want the the juliet lewis protagonist
and and can relate to that more than
nothing against sandra bullock but her
characters i
admire sandra's career but her
characters are always sort of very
similar
and sort of this like savior you know
middle class i'm gonna
fix everything and not all of us can
totally relate to that
and again nothing against it but i think
it has to be something
a little there is a damaged quality to
some of juliet's roles and i yeah
i like that yeah julia luz always brings
such a vulnerability
even in natural-born killers i mean
she's ferocious in that
and yet you know the flashbacks to her
childhood the
the hostile relationships that she has
with woody harrelson's character
um you can understand where her anger is
coming from like it's never
even when she's a monster she plays it
in a way where you still feel some sense
of
sympathy for her or at the very least
empathy like you like i
understand why she's acting that way and
that to me i mean that's a that's a
great
villain and i also about those movies i
mean the villain was the main characters
in those movies
um you know kind of anti-heroes if you
want to call them that
uh and you know there's got to be
something redeeming there was a great
quote that said uh
even the devil's convinced himself he's
doing the right thing
so you know with any of these you know
villain characters or anti-heroes if you
don't feel like you can understand why
they're doing it
then it's not a good character and
juliet lewis is phenomenal at portraying
that
you